[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein leckeres mittagessen
und war werde ich kein wort rezept
machen es hat sich ein bisschen moderner
an als ein eintopf betreut einen
kartoffeleintopf schöner deutschen
getrübten ja genau so typische
schwäbische einflüsse dieser
kartoffeleintopf besteht aus kartoffeln
gemüse und wir werden später noch ein
paar wisst ihr mit rein schneiden
aber man kann den eintopf auch ganz gut
begann zu bereiten wenn man die bisschen
weglässt und statt butter einfach öl
nimmt dann ist für mich alles begann
zeigt euch jetzt gleich mal die zutaten
was sie noch dazu sagen möchte ich finde
ein topf rezepte gerade im herbst und
winter immer super weil man so
superschnell vorbereiten kann und man
braucht man sich nur einen topf hat ganz
wenig geschehen
und ich finde es passt einfach zur
warmen jahreszeit einfach und ich finde
das musst du viel zu selten
aber deshalb selber keine suppe ohne mit
suppen eintöpfe das so sachen überhaupt
es ist nicht dieser effekt aber die
schmecken so gehen ja ist es auch so man
muss auch ehrlich sagen hier ist die
zutaten günstig das ganze rezept kostet
vielleicht wenn die würste klasse
goethes euro das 56 euro bestellt haben
sogar noch bio salat und alles sah nach
gemüse
deswegen macht es nach und ihr halt auch
das video es ist jetzt wirklich keine
super mega tochter source und vor allem
rezept was man im alltag super
integrieren kann und der samira
schmeckte ein traurig school also dieses
super gerne zeigt euch mal die wenigen
zutaten
ich brauche für den einen topf 2
esslöffel butter das sind etwa 40 gramm
ich habe mich ein bisschen gemüse und
zwar zwei karotten etwas knollensellerie
dass zilien wurzel 2 zwiebeln und etwas
laub habe ich ein kilo kartoffeln
es sind vorwiegend festkochende 1 bund
petersilie 500 gramm würstchen kaffee
prinz christian i hab ich noch salz
pfeffer muskat 2 lorbeerblätter und
chili und eineinhalb liter wasser ich
mache das jetzt so ich würde das ganze
jetzt mit der küchenmaschine aber ihr
könnt das ganze auch natürlich mit einem
messer oder zum beispiel mit dem
alligator fein würfeln
aber es geht jetzt halten bis der
schneller
[Musik]
jetzt nämlich das gemüse und ihr könnt
natürlich auch maria war dieses gemüse
her so das suppengemüse das heißt das
bringt den ganzen geschmack mit rein
man kann es auch zusammenkaufen dagegen
aber man kann es auch zum beispiel
einzeln kaufen das ist günstiger da hat
man natürlich mehr menge aber einfacher
ist es diese suppengemüse im bund zu
kaufen
seit überall ja und man kann es aber
auch schon fein schneiden und zum
beispiel einfrieren und jetzt werde ich
das ganze gemüse würfeln
nämlich noch die kartoffeln die wirklich
gibt's auch aber für die
petersilienwurzel und für die sellerie
also die sind einfach zu hart würde ich
jetzt nicht im workflow machen da bleibt
es mir nicht hängen und wir alle garten
schmeckt sind sehr hart das gemüse das
schneidet dann gleich einfach mit dem
netz
und in laufen die bisschen schneiderin
scheiben
mit
[Musik]
es ist alles fein geschnitten und jetzt
gebe ich die butter in einem heißen topf
nimmt jetzt auch einen großen topf um
besser jetzt gleich das ganze gemüse
darin anbraten
und zwar für etwa zwei bis drei minuten
der nachwuchs gemüse jetzt mit dem
wasser ab bei mir haben jetzt hier nicht
ganz ein und hat glitter reingepasst
deswegen mit noch 300 milliliter zufügen
einfach so dass es sehr gut bedeckt ist
das aufkochen lassen und mit dem deckel
etwa 20 minuten köcheln lassen
[Musik]
werden im kochen ruhig auch immer mal
wieder um und die gewürze sind sie auf
jeden fall auch nicht vergessen
deswegen gebe ich jetzt als pfeffer
chili und auch die laubblätter mit rein
jetzt ist das gemuese schön weich und
ich kann die suche fertigstellen
ich nehme jetzt etwa ein drittel oder
ein bisschen weniger von der suppe raus
mit dem teil fein pürieren
ein super wir ganz durcheinander
gekommen ein toller wurf ein eintopf
fans ein bisschen was raus da kann ich
das bald verlieren dann wird es ein
bisschen zäh mich reichtum und der rest
bleibt schön fein gewürfelt und da kann
ich jetzt aber schon mal die würste mit
dazu geben wir können die nämlich schon
mal ein paar minuten gesprochen
kommt es hier wieder mit dazu dann seht
ihr auch gleich dass der eintopf ein
bisschen blick flüssiger auch wird und
jetzt muss ich nur noch kurz abschmecken
mit salz pfeffer und die petersilie fein
hacken
die gebe ich nämlich später nach oben
drauf und gas
[Musik]
dazu nein gibt kein vor oder
zurückdrehen
das karate drin ein bisschen ja gleich
selber importieren aber eigentlich
frauen zudem ein verflixt dazu hat alles
mit drin
bei mir ist einfach so
bei uns gibt's zu anderen uthlande brot
gegessen erst wenn meine eltern auch
aber findest du nicht dass da viel ich
find's toll dass firma weil die schon
mehr oben sieht halt aus angst und das
so und daran erkennbar natürlich wenn
die würstchen oben schwimmen dann heißt
das es frische würstchen sind ja nicht
heißt dass er tot
nein das heißt die schwimmhalle einfach
oben ich glaube dass ein wechsel steht
ein bisschen mit dem eier frischer test
aber wenn die eier oben schwimmen im
wasser dann sind sie schlecht meint man
sich draußen kalt und etwas deftiges und
ich jetzt einfach alles zu vereinfachen
und man kann einfach alles in einen topf
reinschmeißen und hat einen super
leckeres gericht will mir keine löst ihn
ab oder veganer einfach weglassen so ist
es
die verbrannt und super geld jetzt noch
ein kleiner tipp und zwar mit schwein
ist geben
damit möchte und daher kein schwein mehr
kannst du auch die sich kümmern
es ist wohl diese ganz pro jahr wird ist
was du gar genommen hast das ist ein
maler große rings lustig dass die großen
rindsfüßer einfach zu groß ja ich bin
die auf ist groß man kann wirklich
mittel dünnerem kleineren nehmen
aber ich bin so froh eigentlich gar
nicht vorstellen ansonsten lassen macht
was man auch als jetzt auch lust
bekommen habt auf diesen super leckeren
eintopf rangeht auf zehn.de da steht das
rezept für euch und falls ihr euch wie
der morath auch weitere eindruck rezepte
um rezepte wünscht dann schreibt mir
gerne in die kommentare
oder könnt ihr auch gerne
lieblingsrezept schicken und ich mache
dann für euch nach
das geht auch ja und mit suppen komme ja
auch gut aufnehmen einfach bis um gesund
und bewusst essen und sich bewegen
also viel spaß machen und wir sehen uns
beim nächsten mal wieder biss dann
tschüss die spritze suppe findet ihr ab
sofort welche note
[Musik]